Kristen Fisher at the White House with
new information on what really went down
last night on the North Lawn Kadeem
Kristen
Brett moments ago the u.s. Park Police
put out a statement saying that no tear
gas was used during that push back of
protesters in Lafayette Square this time
last night now Democrats on Capitol Hill
have been saying all day that those
protesters were peaceful but the park
police now say that some protesters
became combative and threw projectiles
forcing them to escalate
one day after law enforcement used
flashbangs and rubber bullets on
protesters to pave the way for president
Trump to make this walk to st. John's
Church the president was back at another
place of Prayer st. John Paul the second
National Shrine but this moment of
remembrance was quickly followed by a
scathing statement from the Archbishop
of Washington who said I find it
baffling and reprehensible that any
Catholic facility would allow itself to
be so egregiously misused and
manipulated and today outside st. John's
Church but counselor to the president
Kellyanne Conway says President Trump
has nothing to repent for why the
president felt compelled to walk there
why he held that Bible up that is a
symbol to everyone that we will not
allow arsonists an anarchist who set
that fire ablaze according to a senior
official at the Justice Department the
decision to widen the perimeter around
the White House was made early Monday
morning but when Attorney General Bill
Barr arrived in Lafayette Square Monday
afternoon the
had not yet been executed the official
claims a protester threw a water bottle
at the Attorney General and that's when
Bill Barr gave the order to push
protesters back before President Trump
walked out the police did not respond
other than to move the protesters back I
thought what the President did in
visiting the church was not only
appropriate it was needed but Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer calls it
unconstitutional an abuse of
presidential power and possibly illegal
the President of the United States
ordered troops to attack peaceful
American citizens exercising their
constitutional rights by tear gassing
them in a public park while military
helicopters flew overhead president
Trump is now warning scenes like this a
military helicopter hovering over
protesters could soon extend to other
hotspots
unless governors and mayor's regain
control already active duty troops have
been flown into the DC area but have yet
to be deployed if a city or state
refuses to take the actions that are
necessary to defend the life and
property of their residents then I will
deploy the United States military and
quickly solve the problem for them now
in order for President Trump to deploy
any active duty troops on US soil he
would have to invoke a more than 200
year old law the in serration
insurrection act White House officials
tell me that it is something that is
being seriously considered but that it
would only be used as a last resort
Brett Kristen Fisher live the North Lawn
Kristen thank you